a seventh grader in Michigan is earning
praise for his heroic actions on a
school bus this week so you can see the
bus driver here begin to lose
Consciousness in this video right 13
year old Dylan Reeves he is 13 years old
he Springs into action he hits the
brakes he steers the bus away from
traffic safely bringing it to a full
stop then he screams for someone to call
9-1-1 First Responders were there within
minutes and the bus driver was taken to
the hospital Dylan's parents spoke to
reporters yesterday
I can't even
breath how much
proudness you know like I'm extremely
proud of him it does this shouldn't it's
kind of like why us you know but
it's a it's an honor I mean we got a
little hero
yeah uh the school superintendent says
Dylan will be recognized for his bravery
and local leaders plan to honor him as
well I like that his dad said when he
first got the call he thought Dylan was
in trouble that'd be my parents like
what'd he do now oh he's a hero
situation so for him at 13. a lot about
who he is it does well job Mom and Dad
what Mom and Dad I was going to say good
job mommy is the Poise right yeah
hit the brakes steer it out of traffic
call 9-1-1 young hero right there that's
right